it's not pretty you know he does the
technique right and then he goes in it's
like oh he's gonna do it but what they
don't show you is this part
a man is suing
BW3 is where Buffalo Wild Wings oh good
they should be out of business that
pricey boneless wings are basically just
nuggets that's true okay so he spawned a
class action lawsuit wait what's a
boneless swing I'm I'm really this is
I'm emotional about this one this one's
interesting right I'm really emotional
it is interesting describe to my gear do
they actually debone the the the ball
that's the last no bro and also if
you're eating bones it's just tender
you're a [__] wait what whoa you're a
[__] if you I'm a [__] yeah you're a
[__] bro first of all let me just say
something the grit this oh no no no no
no this is it I'm get in if you don't
eat the [__] cartilage on the side of
your wings and you [__] do boneless
wings stay the [__] home and Order
chicken nuggets yeah oh order from
McDonald's I don't want to see your mild
buffalo sauce oh you eat spices food so
I'll forgive you wait wait wait he does
eat spices what if what if like
okay what if I got you got the wings
right but then there's nothing
on the side
found them you have a bones why don't
you just order muscles hey can I get a
bunch of mussels and Bone please with
some muffalo sauce
you need flavor oh can I get like a
bunch of like [__] tendons and like
some barbecue sauce thing can I get
processed he's upset this guy who soon
doesn't understand how they make this
it's called processed food so you eating
fake [__] who am I look at me oh am I
eating fake [__] oh no what am I gonna
do look how rich he is dude he only
needs caviar look at this outfit bro
Buffalo Wild Wings you really only like
really you're you're boneless 100. can I
say sleep for boneless I like boneless
too but I like the combo you need you
need I like to have the rattle I know I
like just the flats you know that that's
fine you're still in the bone Zone we're
still in the bone Zone
if I have to be in the bone Zone yes
drumsticks only that's fine drum six
holidays I'll play with that I wish they
cut off that [__] bonus wait so wait
I'm gonna ask you we just named this
show the bones
welcome back to the bones welcome back
to the Bone Zone bones only so do you
mean uh do you eat red meat red meat
yeah
um like you're not a red meat guy you're
not a redmi guy no okay because my next
question is if you order a steak will
you get it bone on or bone off I'll get
bone off bonus if I go to a restaurant
if I go to a restaurant and I'm getting
a steak I'm getting okay first of all
what kind of beef are you getting
at a steakhouse what's my mood am I
feeling a little alive
it's us it's us it's us we're at a great
Steakhouse we're chilling Wine's flowing
but the ones with the bones Bart is
paying yeah if you get the ones with the
bones it's not only explained no no it's
like this [__] fat we're not talking
like a tomahawk rib eye like yeah thank
you Joe what are you talking about let's
get that big bonus yeah bro that's
flavor baby no that's fine but are you
talking about like a T-bone for a steak
yeah for a steak for a steak if I'm
cooking at my house
why because I don't have to pay as much
when I go to a [__] a restaurant why
are you going bone in I want you to say
it to me
if I go to a uh a steakhouse and they
have a nice like porterhouse or
something or a T-bone yeah I'll I'll
[__] with that
I'm not a poor right I'm not trying to I
like how he said it a poor he used he
said he a poo a poor who eats the bones
the liquids
the most attractive that I ever that I
look is when you see me gnawing on
chicken bones
is that your headshot yeah like an
Indian person who hasn't eaten in five
and a half weeks yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know he doesn't understand because
what he doesn't understand is that the
amount of muscularity it takes me to get
through the bones he doesn't understand
I'm primed and ready
I need to be all muscular so when I'm
jerking my dick off there it's more
efficient strongest muscle on the human
body is right here baby hey you don't
think you don't that's gross that makes
me feel good
now he's like he's like wait he's like
he's like me
world peace
it's quite the era but you don't have
like you know you ever see some people
with their chicken drumsticks or their
Flats they have a special tank oh yeah
where they pull them you don't do that
stuff I've seen it where they put it in
their mouth
so one of my buddies he showed me how to
do it I for honestly a Chinese guy did
you guys make out after almost almost
but he does it and it's honest
the most gayest [__] ever just sucking
on a wig it's honestly like because yeah
it's like it's blow job skills it's not
pretty you know he does a technique
right and then he goes in it's like oh
he's gonna do it but what they don't
show you is this part
oh yeah and you're like you're gonna
choke but it comes out clean and clean
it looks like they're brushing their
teeth yeah
and they go I don't think it's
impressive I only want to do that in the
privacy of my own home I don't want to
do that in public it's too much I don't
know how much would you do that in front
of your mother yeah 100 bro are you sure
you forget it she said it works you know
my parents are from India dude they
don't waste food but but you eat chicken
bones like like you're eating [__]
impress his mom I'd be impressive that's
my son
my mom will never see this I'd be
impressed if you like bones so much that
you get bones put into things that don't
happen
can I get some Jello bonus broth is made
right you guys know how broth is made
right bone broth yeah that's the only
way to make good all of the P it's all
the bones that no one's eating carcass
someone is like I could make a lot of
money off this and sell it to to goop
for five dollars
[Laughter]
pound [__] too I don't think we're
gonna didn't she say that she's like
black coffee and bone broth something
she does a lot of crazy stuff huh she's
crazy doesn't she do like the vagina the
glitter the [__] glitter thing what's
vagina steaming yes wait have you guys
seen those chairs that are used for that
it's like a facial for your vagina I had
no idea but I was I was just looking on
OfferUp at furniture and then I saw a
[__] look like a lazy boy with a
toilet shut the [__] it Steve's it I was
like what the why does it have a hole
there's specific Furniture yeah oh dude
what am I there's a name for it too but
you were on offer up so it was a used
piece yes it was used
it looks like it just looks like a nice
chair but there's a hole cut out looks
like you're supposed to [__] in it but
you're not you're supposed to put like
something to steam upwards it's just a
guy like this
he says the boneless wings are not
actually part of a chicken wing they're
instead slices of chicken breast deep
fried like wings isn't that better and
this is a clear-cut cake it's actually
yeah it just sounds like chicken strips
yeah yeah or chicken tender and he says
this is false advertising it's a shape
it should not be permitted as consumers
should be able to rely on the plain
meaning of a product's name and receive
what they are promised he's probably
gonna win but do people actually serve
like do they take the meat off the wings
and then they make it into a boneless
wing is that that's what I would think
if
swings I would think it would just be
the wings with no bone in it
come on it's my favorite part of the
article are you ready there would be
like a giant Hollow hole in it but also
it would be 75 for a dozen yeah this is
what I'm saying too much [__] time
how much prep it's not fine guy claims
he purchased the Boneless Wings in
January but after learning what they are
made of he said he regretted his
decision
you know what we're friends this guy we
we think alike
as a result Mr Holland is his name Mr
Holland suffered a financial injury as a
result of the defendant's false and
deceptive how many weeks did he buy he
just bought like a 1799 hey you know
what though I hope this guy wins because
somebody needs to take down bb dubs dude
I don't know you're not a fan of the
organization in general how come because
well it's just I just feel like what's
the other hot wing place the famous
Hooters baby Wingstop Wingstop is just
better and every time it is good
yeah you don't that's the thing you
never eat inside of wing stuff do you
want to eat inside of a bee yes every
single time dude where are you watching
me atmosphere the women the beautiful
women yeah yeah that's true no but it is
fun to watch games you know what I love
that place they have zero vegetarian
items
they have they have [__] carrot
sticks that's the only thing even though
it's like it has meat products yeah
they're like cheese curds I think
they're funny
so that's why so I'm just surrounded by
this this guy by like when you go to
Walmart you can buy like [__] Marie
Calendars or like does Buffalo Wild
Wings have like frozen [__] you can no
he was at the restaurant chain oh he
could have [__] complained at the
restaurant does that does that mean what
is he confused about like regret his
decision because the statement is 50
true because it's still boneless there
are no bones so he's okay there wings
but it's the wings but the breast is
that not a part of the Wings no no it's
not made up no the wing is different
it's connected to this the breast is
actually white meat and the wing is dark
meat yup does that mean Buffalo Wild
Wings are the only people that call it
boneless wings when they're not actually
wings no but what about chilies they all
do that no oh they all do that yeah yeah
so does a Wingstop I've been on a Korean
Fried Chicken
okay I just been tearing where have you
been going there's this place called
BonChon is good
BBQ like that's like barbecue chicken or
something like that I don't know that
place is good they have boneless wings
are they not as good as the regular
Wings there yeah they're not as good
because they're just like cut up pieces
of chicken thighs yeah deep fried batter
and it's like all right it's fine I just
know there's a chicken though you guys
like boneless wings
I have established that yeah I like
chicken nuggets I like that you guys
should try back on the Indian food stuff
there's a South Indian dish called
chicken 65. what's that like chicken
soup right 65. why 65. I recommend it
foreign
[Music]